good morning believe nation today's
message is be mentally tough over to you
Robert Kraft awake the TV go you know
you look at people who are successful
and a lot of people had a lot of talent
but who aren't and it's usually mental
toughness and preparation that make the
difference and then when the going gets
rough you hang in there if you believe
in whatever your mission is being an
entrepreneur is tough and I think it's
something that most people don't think
about as you're getting into it you
think it's going to be tough but you
don't realize just how tough it's going
to be and I always said it's one of the
hardest things that you're ever gonna do
in your life and you can never fully
prepare for it because even if you
create your best case and meeting case
in worst-case scenario it's always
harder it's always worse than your worst
case scenario and it's draining and its
soul crushing and it's tough because
quite often you are being forced to step
outside your comfort zone right you're
being forced to step outside what your
friends and family think you can do
you're stepping outside what you might
think you can do when momentum is gone
and you wake up the next day and you
don't have any energy any momentum going
any desire to want to keep going
something keeps you moving forward
because you love what you do and because
you're mentally tough you're going to
have the friends in your life tell you
that your idea is stupid you're going to
have customers give you feedback and and
give you a lot of negative feedback and
tell you all the reasons why they're not
going to bark from you you're going to
have a lot of haters who look at your
product or service and the little man in
your life triumph over the little man
you're going to have that little man who
just points out all the flaws in your
business idea tells you all the reasons
why it's not going to work out
and you know have the right friends
because you don't come from money
because you are not smart enough look at
you you're never gonna and when you're
first starting it's a huge challenge
because you haven't figured it all out
yet right of course is going to be holes
in the plan you haven't actually
launched it yet and gotten customers
coming in and it's so easy to listen to
all those negative people in your life
and say to yourself I'm not gonna be
able to do this I'm not going to be able
to make it you know maybe this isn't for
me and I remember when I did that I
remember when I felt worthless and
having no value and the soul crushing us
of telling my business partner that I
quit right when I've never quit anything
before my life who I was telling my
partner I quit I can't do this anymore I
want to do something where I feel like
I'm actually adding value to somebody's
life and those are the daily struggles
that you face as an entrepreneur and the
thing that gets you through is being
mentally tough and loving what you do so
the question of the day today is I'm
curious to find out what is the hardest
thing that you've had to do as an
entrepreneur give me something to help
prepare you and help develop that mental
toughness the hardest thing that you've
had to do leave it in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and i'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events press 0